je crois qu'il faut se garder d' évaluer
la qualité d'un état en fonction de
l'importance de ces prélèvements
d'ailleurs sur l'idée que les
prélèvements ont baissé partout c'est
parce qu'à c'est pas le cas en france
par exemple il ya un très bel article
dans le financial times aujourd'hui qui
explique justement que la baisse de la
présence de l'état est un mythe depuis
quarante ans que ce n'est pas vrai
l'état ne s'est pas retirée il a il a
changé de forme il est toujours aussi
présent il est plus présent que jamais
par exemple à travers la politique
monétaire puisqu'il a fini par remettre
la main sur la banque centrale qui
finalement c'est ce que les états lui
dépend donc c'est encore plus vrai en
france peut parler néolibéralisme en
france et est une est une blague
absolument incroyable ça quand on
regarde les chiffres il n'y a jamais eu
néolibérale ça fait 40 ans aujourd'hui
qu'on aligne un budget en déficit de
plus en plus en déficit avec une aide
qui ne fait qu'augmenter donc ya jamais
eu de baisse de dépenses
il ya juste eu malheureusement de
l'argent qui est pour le moins mal le
mal employé alors quand on parle de
néolibéralisme très souvent en réalité
on sait pas très bien de part en part et
en fait derrière on parle du capitalisme
de connivence c'est ça probablement l'un
des défauts des états unis il ya un très
bon livre de l'économiste thomas
philippon récemment de great river au
sol qui a très très bien montré comment
les états unis avaient depuis une
vingtaine d'années abandonné justement
est bien la concurrence en laissant les
concentrations se faire évidemment les
gars femmes en sont l'expression la plus
la plus ultime et c'est évidemment des
concentrations qui nuisent au marché
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on dit
on ne remet jamais en cause la victoire
par ko sur le communisme du libre marché
de la libre entreprise dont il est même
pas question de la remettre en cause
et ça finalement c'est quand même le
substrat du libéralisme donc peut-être
que le tournoi jeunes c'est justement le
plus intéressant c'est pas celui
forcément qu'on dit le plus dur c'est
pas forcément le tournant fiscale qui en
effet est un peu en un retour à ce qui a
déjà été fait mais c'est cette idée que
on va peut-être enfin essayer de faire
pièce aux grandes plate forme quasi
monopolistique qui se développent et ça
c'est très intéressant
[Musique]